Happy Easter enjoy yourselves  and I'm coming down right now to be with  you first lady is coming with me and  maybe I'll get this great Easter Bunny  to come with us don't come without the  Easter Bunny mr. president that's  president Trump and First Lady Melania  Trump hosting the 140 first White House  Easter Egg Roll yesterday those always  fun  this tradition dates back to 1878 among  the guests this year 10 year old Jordan  McGlynn who's battling muscular  dystrophy we first told you about little  Jordan back in 2015 when he became the  face of the right to try campaign that  movement was pushing to get some  patients easier access to experimental  drugs Jordan got nationwide attention  with this hug last year when the  President signed the right to try bill  into law  Jordan ran up and down the White House  lawn yesterday his mom says he was able  to run around because of the treatments  they fought for I'm glad to see he had a  nice time yeah it's nice to see him  running